well January ain't going down without a
flight I can tell you that the boy next
door that has got to be the most generic
ass title I've ever heard in my life
so the boy next door stars Jennifer
Lopez she's this hot-ass teacher she
looks like Jennifer Lopez let's be
honest totally if I had a teacher like
that she's a mom she's going through
divorces she gets this convenient ass
plot device called this dude is really
attractive dude who ends up moving into
the house next door is a 20 years old
which right there was like I thought you
were in her class who saw that in the
trailer here's how the movie does it his
parents died a couple years ago so we
had to take a couple years off school so
he's a 20 year old who's a senior in
high school because they want to make
this seedy ass movie about the student
who bangs a teacher and then bad things
happen they don't want to be creepy
about it so they need to make him 20
years old I guess so in a moment of
weakness JLo goes over there and they
bang and then after that this dude it's
like fatal attraction JLo's like stop
messing with my life and he's like but
you look like you and I just lived out
every junior high / high school students
dream and now we have this sloppy ass
mess I'll be honest with you I wanna
here are the positives the positives
Jennifer Lopez is really attractive she
just is she is physical perfection
that's what JLo is Fabian said you're
locked into an hour and a half long
thriller starring the third judge of
American Idol and the dude from step up
all in bream folks run for thy life
I read that nothing in this movie makes
us the movie doesn't even do a good job
at transitioning from scene to scene you
don't know how much time has passed
between scenes example there's a scene
she's in her jammies and she's sitting
down she's ready to go to bed and she
looks and she sees to do to cross the
street all undressing and [ __ ] she's
like ooh you saw me and then the next
scene she's out on a date with her
friend and they're double dating and
[ __ ] so you're like okay it's the next
night because she was clearly getting
ready to go to bed that night then the
date doesn't go well then she's home the
dude call he's like hey want to come
over and help me cook a turkey and when
the shits going down he's like when you
saw me tonight I was like whoa tonight
are you telling me she got into her
jammies clearly ready to go to bed and
then she went out on a date in down
down and then came back and then was
drinking wine and then Bank you'd like
all that should happen in one nights
stop it movie stop it that's just one
scene in the movie it wouldn't be worth
bringing up but that does illustrate how
sloppy ask the movie just feels
throughout everything in the movie is
just really convenient they have the
whole thing going on where the neighbor
kid the Jennifer Lopez tagged the
unstable the main guy he's hanging out
with Jennifer Lopez's son he's feeding
him bad advice if he gets pissed off at
his dad and he ends up getting pissed at
his dad I'm like alright if you're gonna
take notes from a Karate Kid movie don't
take it from Karate Kid three take it
from one or two show that you have class
director of Alex Cross you start phoning
it in at a point like I'm a grown-ass
man I review movies this is what I do
so cheap shots cheap things like skin
they don't sell me on a movie I'm above
that I like the thing so anyway but in
the movies so shitty you start phoning
it in you're like let's write it are
maybe we'll see some JLo Teddy that's
what I'm here for now I'm here I have to
grind through it let's just maybe
there's JLo titty that stop there's
nothing in this movie nothing is in the
titty and nothing as in funny thing
drops you JLo for keeping class and a
rated R movie you could have shown titty
but you didn't the acting is not great
the main dude in this movie he's just
one-dimensional last character he starts
acting crazy at one point like you're
like ooh this guy's crazy the problem is
if you're gonna play crazy you have to
be a good actor to sell me on the fact
that you're crazy
Disney's acting captain step up all in I
didn't see that one I want to be honest
I didn't see step up all in but
something tells me it's about where his
career Peaks maybe the episode stint
that he did on Pretty Little Liars
I am D beat the guy before I film this
that's how I know this [ __ ] they
suspected me of my popcorn ball like
Pretty Little Liars love the transitions
suck the acting's not great the tensions
not there then like the last act of the
movies like many people are gonna die
but the problem is no tension built and
no character building happen that made
you give a [ __ ] about this last act like
alright maybe the doodle get like maybe
something will land on his head and
crush him it'll be entertaining like you
know Jason or something sometimes you
got to call a spade a spade guys and
sometimes I got to inform you that the
boy next door is [ __ ] so your
favorite psycho stalker movie what is it
whatever it is comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more